For much of the 19th
century.
Spike Island is one of
the most infamous prisons
on earth. It is
synonymous with death and
suffering. Gripped by
the new evidence,
archaeologist Kirk
French is traveling to
the star shaped prison
on the Irish Coast,
hunting for Bastion
three.
Much of Spike Island now
lies in ruins.
But at its peak, this
prison was ten times the
size of Alcatraz.
The huge banks
surrounding the jail were
built by the inmates
themselves over 150 years
ago. But it's a hidden
cell block that drew
French here. And to find
it, he's meeting
archaeologist Barra
O'Donovan, an expert on
Spike Island. O'donovan
leads French to the
entrance of a series of
underground tunnels.
Oh.